[Music]
hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be talking about takedowns in
aikido so i've made several conrad
videos uh talking about the udeo say i
think there are two ureose which is the
the arm takedown is what that means
videos that are up on youtube and
there's several more on my patreon page
and i kind of talk about uh what the
spectrum of the takedown looks like so
from getting the position from getting
to the position for the takedown and
then how the position works out and then
if the position gets turned over how
that works out as well right so so
looking at all those different
possibilities in that
so today i actually want to talk about
percentage of takedown ability right so
how high percentage is a takedown versus
the kinds of contexts we're talking
about in aikido and how that kind of
varies we're not going to do any
sparring in this video today so sorry
but i didn't want to set up all that
right now i'm just going to give you
some some things to think about when
you're looking at takedowns in aikido
and and how that works out so i'm going
to call josh over here we're going to go
to work josh
all right so let's talk about takedowns
what i'm going to give you right now is
it's just thought experiments for you so
it's a way to think about what's going
on here and and when we start to talk
about takedowns a very valid question to
ask is how high percentage is that is
that a high percentage technique and
this is something that's been
really commonly used for a while now in
martial arts where
i i'm asking how likely is it that i'm
going to pull that off so so sure you
can construct any kind of crazy takedown
you want and it might even work once in
a thousand times tried but that would be
what we consider a low percentage
technique then there are techniques that
we will see often we'll see those
techniques all the time and so if you go
look at a judo competition or a
greco-roman competition or brazilian
jiu-jitsu competition there are throws
that you will see over and over and over
that day and those are what we call high
percentage take down so those are
takedowns that are done uh often because
they're they're really good okay
now we're going to talk about
when we look at the ikio takedown a lot
of times so so we've seen a lot of
questions coming up on this channel
recently of um well how likely is it
that you would even get an echo take
down and i think that's a very valid
question and i kind of want to present a
way to look at it for you to kind of
start to think about it i'm not going to
try to justify
that aikido is a high percentage
takedown because i personally don't
think it's a high percentage takedown
but i'm going to show you why it
probably exists and why we need to think
about it okay so first we need to go we
need to ask what are high percentage
takedowns okay so i think we could
definitely make the argument that a
double leg takedown is a high percentage
takedown okay so you could go to
wrestling tournaments you'll see it all
the time you'll see it in brazilian jiu
jitsu all kinds of places you'll see it
a lot
or a single leg so some variation of a
leg tackling technique right so some
kind of technique that goes down here
low and drives into this guy and knocks
them off balance that's a high
percentage technique now it's high
percentage because i've bound up his
legs in some way either one or both of
them and i'm driving my entire body
weight into him and knocking him back so
even if this guy's a big guy if i have a
good single or double leg i can probably
still take them down so even for us a
pretty good size advantage if i have a
good uh takedown like that i can
probably get this guy so leg tackling
takedowns are high percentage takedowns
okay
some kind of body controlling takedown
right now that can either be like a big
judo hip toss or it could be like a
greco-roman soup play or something like
that right so so any one of these kind
of techniques and
any one of these these forms of
techniques are going to be a high
percentage technique and we're going to
see that we can see it from the front or
the back or the side we're going to see
these a lot so if we went to a wrestling
tournament or a brazilian jitsu terms
your term you can see there's a lot
those are super high percentage how
likely is it that i'm going to take a
guy down with this okay now in a context
where this guy is is trying to stop me
from taking him down and i've got him
and i want to take him down probably not
very high percentage why is that not
high percentage well one because i only
have control of his arm so if we look at
why the double leg takedown's good it's
good because i'm controlling both of his
legs which is what he's going to balance
himself with or even one of his legs and
he's going to balance himself with those
so if he doesn't have those he can
balance himself let's look at the high
percentage body control takedown right
well i'm able to pick up his entire body
with this and by doing that he won't
have legs to support him so that's a
high percentage throw or take down as
well but when i'm looking at this i'm
not really controlling his legs now sure
i could trip or something but that would
be a different technique than just
taking him down with his arms um and and
we could say that's a variation we come
around to that but but this is not going
to be very high percentage and so this
is why you don't see it in judo or
brazilian determinants it's not high
percentage okay so in that context why
don't you see eco takedowns in in
regular grappling situations like
tournaments or even go to a gym where
they're sparring wrigley you won't see
them because it's not high percentage
now let's see why it might exist in
aikido now if this guy has a knife in
his hand or any kind of weapon a club or
whatever you want to say a gun whatever
it is right okay now if i do a double
leg take down on this guy the second
i've come down here i'm completely
exposed to that knife right so i can't
stop that knife from coming in right now
of course i could come up here maybe i
could get a single leg off of this but
still in order to get to that position i
endanger myself by shooting everything
down in here and
taking a good chance of getting cut
further even once i get the takedown
unless i've somehow secured that hand
i'm not going to be able to take him
down now you can say of course well then
you would just shoot a double leg and
grab the wrist it's really hard to grab
the wrist out of the air so if you've
never tried that you should try grabbing
the wrist out of the air meaning that
while i'm dedicated down here and i see
that knife and i go like this it's going
to be real hard for me to get that hand
right so it's going to be hard for me to
get it not impossible but this maybe
isn't the best way to go at trying to
take someone down who's got something in
their hand or could potentially have
something in their hand okay now what
about an upper body hold now if i got
the upper body hold in like say i got a
waist lock right of course we can see
this is not a great idea because he's
easily able here to stab i could though
cinch over the top or grab the hand to
get that upper body hold now we might
see a throw similar to this in judo
because judo comes from old style jiu
jitsu which is the same
lineage as aikido comes from this old
school and you'll see this arm
controlling now
the problem with this is even when i
come in here like this he still has a
good chance of getting that knife hand
free right if he pulls this directly
away from me now i've got to come in
here and get it now if when he pulls the
hand away he puts this hand against my
chest now i'm in a really horrible
position so this kind of movement which
could work to keep him from stabbing can
be kind of dangerous right so because
there's a lot of bad things that can
happen there now of course if we look at
the percentages that won't always happen
sometimes i will throw them down i have
taken people down with a knife in their
hand this way before so totally a doable
thing you can totally do it but it's
probably going to be kind of dangerous
so would i throw them yes would i
probably get stabbed for it probably yes
right so both of our common unarmed
takedown techniques are not going to be
all that great in an armed situation
okay now let's look at if we were doing
this technique and we'll talk about why
it's bad and we'll talk about why it's
good now if we're in this kind of
position you can see my whole body's
away from him now let's say he switched
hands because that's an option he has
now notice i still have the entirety of
his body holding him away from me so if
he reaches in there for stabbing you can
see it's really difficult for him to get
that and in fact the more he reaches so
i'll just let him reach in right now
okay so he's just re
good reach in okay look see how he's
nicely reaching into stab now the second
he nicely reaches into stab and i extend
into that arm he goes off balance
because the act of turning this half of
his body in which is what he doesn't
want to do right now because he knows
he's going to go off balance okay that
act is what makes it possible to do that
echo so him switching and trying to stab
him from the other side is actually what
makes that possible now it's dangerous
because there's a knife i don't i don't
i never in my brain think that guy's got
a knife and i want to go get him right
so this is part of the big difference of
why aikido is different than other
martial arts but understand that from
this position what's up from this
position what's possible is he can
switch hands he can totally switch hands
and i still haven't lost that much of my
ability to deal with him and this also
extends into not taking him down but
just going whoa i need to get out of
there which is what aikido is really all
about so i understand when we're kind of
talking about this stuff we're also
talking about the difference between
traditional jiu-jitsu and uh modern
jiu-jitsu right okay
now let's say he doesn't
switch and there's all kinds of ways in
aikido we have to keep to make it very
difficult for him to switch so all kinds
of little ways but let's say right now
he's just not switching okay now
when i start to take him down i am
constantly keeping that knife away from
me which is good so that makes it a
really good
type of takedown for this situation so
it is a lower percentage takedown
overall if we are looking at getting the
takedown then it's going to be lower
percentage but for the the situation of
a knife it's the only kind of situation
where you're going to get them down now
udeo say which just means an arm
takedown is one of a variation of things
this could also become a rokyo so if
taking them down is the number one
objective then a rocchio will become
higher percentage than an ekyo i could
also do something like variations of
russian two on ones or all kinds of
things that you will find in other
unarmed martial arts so so those kinds
of things will appear but the reason you
won't see the regular high percentage
takedowns in aikido is because we're
always accounting for a weapon and so
that means we're going to relegate
ourselves to a slightly lower percentage
set of techniques that allows us to take
care of ourselves now when we start to
transition this from
uh japanese jiu jitsu which is
essentially what we're seeing now is
kind of the ideas in japanese jitsu to
aikido we'll see a whole different set
in aikido i don't even want to get this
guy i want to get away from this guy
always so if i have him in this
percentage and are in this position and
he's at all difficult to take down i
will either shove him away from me if
i'm stronger than him or move behind him
if he's stronger than me those are my
goals right so that's ikea and what
aikido is doing aikido takedowns only
happen when he's already inherently off
balance right and so that doesn't mean
that i have magical powers in the second
i touch him he's off balance it means
that in the struggle of him trying to
get me he found himself off balance and
he was he was falling down right so
i hope that kind of helps frame this
stuff for you a little bit better the
techniques the takedowns we have in
aikido are not super high percentage
takedowns but the high percentage
takedowns that you would use would be
deadly if their hands were both free now
there's a slightly lower percentage set
of takedowns that you can use that
control the hand and it does a good job
of that right so and those could be
something you know from a russian two on
one or something like that from
wrestling which which could be a good
high percentage technique there are some
problems with that too but but could be
a better higher percentage technique um
but
that's only when there's a weapon being
accounted for right so that's what we're
doing with the weapon is we're
accounting for the weapon in that way um
and then when we're actually looking at
aikido we're only ever looking at aikido
takedowns when either a i'm way bigger
than them and i could do any takedown i
want because i'm just significantly
larger than there but the takedowns i
choose in aikido like this eco takedown
is a good takedown to protect me and him
and anyone around us when i take him
down so it's a better take down for that
kind of situation or a situation where
he just happened to be so off balance
that i could take him down with that and
that was safe for me otherwise we're
always trying to get out of there and
make distance so these are just some
things to think about when you're
looking at aikido and takedowns i hope
this helps i'm christopher hines this is
joshua teehee maya silana mcdaniel's
behind the camera thanks a lot
[Music]
you